what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off alright guys I've got a
brad lee here bang bang I'm super
excited about this we've got lots of
stories to cover he's got all kinds of
wild ideas and doing a bunch of cool
stuff so thanks for coming to do this
hey let's start with your background
everyone knows you I think as the man
who helped uber overcome all of the
regulatory issues and you've done a
bunch of stuff since then but you
actually started out in politics yeah
yeah I did so I kind of got into
politics like I got the tech kind of by
accident that story I was about the
politics kind of a no super weird way -
so would you run for like a high school
student but I was never known or - voted
for me I was definitely not cool enough
to do that but the when I grew up I
liked politics a lot throws interesting
but I was a first generation American
didn't we didn't worship family from
Russia and didn't have any money
wouldn't know anybody but in 1992 the
Democratic convention it was the Bill
Clinton nominating convention was here
at the garden and my dad had a friend
who was a lawyer for the Carpenters
Union this guy Brian O'Dwyer great guy
called me up and said hey I can get you
like a one-day corporators pass to the
convention do you want it sure that'd be
great
so if you look in the newspaper it says
convention noon to midnight
now having now been to a bunch of these
things it's really like a to live in the
rest of us nothing's going on but I
didn't know that so I show up at noon
and the gardens empty right so two guys
running for state Rep them on town on
the stage but kind of ed rendell who at
the time was the mayor of Philly was
sitting the audience by himself and I
had just finished my freshman year of
college the college at Penn so you know
he's the mayor of Philly I go to school
in Philly I'll go say hi what's the
worst that could happen right yeah and
now that I know rondell he was
definitely just talking to the empty
chair like he's talking either way it's
just it might be human being nearby
there might not
and so he would love to have a podcast
then he had a sports radio show that's
amazing Phil he he became a sports radio
host after he was done being governor
you know not joking about him having
something to sell he's awesome and then
that's a rough [ __ ] place to do sports
for sure
so so we had a nice conversation and he
said oh when you get back to school
you're busy and I'm like no not not that
modern sculpture knows what to do and he
said do you want an internship I said
that'd be great I said okay send me no
well cetera so I go home I write a
letter and what I didn't know them but I
know now is a curse bond this is the
black hole government right everything
goes in nothing comes out mm-hmm but
every day I'm going home I'm opening up
the mailbox there's no letter so I get
back to school and this is you know
almost a decade before 9/11 so
Security's not what it is today
I had this insane thought of like well
I'll go see him so I show up at City
Hall and I get to like not his all at
the outer secretary I said it's the man
here and they like were kind of stunned
because in red it's a crazy question
don't people who do that or either
people who are genuinely crazy which I
was in or people like protesting which I
wasn't I was just this like gullible
naive kid don't like wait this kid
actually he may be lost
yeah what they're like finally like do
you own leave a note I'm like okay sure
so I write the note get back on the
subway to go back to the dorm kind of
hit you know so you can't just go see
the mayor I cross that off your list I
look out to the door on the phone rings
and it's the mayor and they said hold
for Adele and he said when you come to
work I said I'll be right there and then
work for him all through can use mine
right back yeah yeah and worked for him
all through college they kind of mainly
blow off class for a couple of years and
worked at City Hall what were you doing
see it was very cool he was really
trying to revive
Philly and did a really great job of it
but there's a really good book called a
prayer for the city by buzz Bissinger
the same guys were Friday Night Lights
about all the work that Ren Delta to
revitalize Philly so he set up his
office of called policy and planning
where it was just he just took this
really smart group of people and said
come up with good ideas for city
government and then I was like you know
basically we do the research it is and
so one of the projects I was doing was
they wanted to come up with a way to
lure
smart graduates out of college into city
government
so as I was researching other cities
programs before the stuff existed in
some places and met the New York City
people and it looked me said how old are
you and I was you know 20 at that point
Oh 19 they're like why don't you just
apply for a program like okay and then
ended up spending the summer between my
junior and senior year of college at the
New York City Parks Department okay and
it was awesome because it really touches
you know it was like summer the offices
in Central Park Commissioner was this
wacky crazy brilliant guy named Henry
Stern and you're just going around the
city to every Park and playground and
doing weird [ __ ] all the time
so went back as the press secretary and
did that for about was you interned and
then you went back like the next summer
or I've never cheated I decide to do is
I had I was going to my senior year but
I took like a whole bunch of classes and
graduated in the semester instead of a
year and went back in January got it a
year the press secretary yeah so I'm
doing the press and you know just like
opening up playgrounds and you know but
you know we'll come up with all things
so this guy would he would do anything
to get attention both for himself and
for park so you could like dress him up
in a crazy costume and he can go get
pressed like over Groundhog's Day one
year we dug a hole in the ground we
dressed him up as a groundhog we buried
him in the ground and then when the
press came he popped up front the front
page of Newsday the next day is when
news day of still paper in the city was
a picture of him in the groundhogs
suit was flakes in the forecast as says
that it's the front page it was this
crazy but really fun a couple years went
to law school but knew I didn't want to
be actually practice law so just kind of
got the degree went back to parks did
that for a couple of more years and then
went to Washington as Chuck Schumer's
communications to right there where I
had arguably the worst job in all of
Washington DC because chuck is some
Westerners here may know is the most
wealth at Oh Trump you could confidently
say Chuck is the most media hungry
member a person watched in most politics
right before we get to this hold on I
have one question for ya so you said
something earlier that was interesting
about the programs to try to get young
kind of intelligent hungry kids out of
great schools into politics yeah how big
of a problem is it in terms of the
quality of the people that we have at
both the national and state level it's a
great question and it is not only having
a problem it is the biggest indicator of
the success or failure of a city so okay
I ended up working for Mike Bloomberg
both in City Hall I know it's just
campaign manager and the thing that made
Mike and I don't know your views on Mike
but I'm gonna bet you liked them the
thing that made Mike so successful if
you made a list let's say that 250
things that got accomplished in 12 years
he'll think of any of those things what
he did was he just hired the most
talented people he could get he said I
don't care about diversity quite frankly
I don't care about politics I just want
the most talent three-button fine and
then he said to every one of them okay
European report to me you got to hire
the same way so every kind of non civil
service job where he had discretion was
just filled with incredibly smart people
who normally would never work in city
government and then he said okay you
know what I'll let you loose come up
with ideas yeah what's your best idea
and if you fail but it's a good idea and
you weren't about it responsibly that's
fine I'll take the heat no problems
people felt comfortable like you know I
had all kinds of crazy ideas you'd like
okay uh-huh and like sometimes they
really were solicited what was the
craziest one we made him the first
politician that they could find in
history who publicly announced the
status of every single one of his
campaign promises whether it was done
not done failed so we cool so when Mike
in his first year this was 2002 it was
Russell coming off 9/11 city economy is
really bad he did a lot of things that
became necessary or popular over time
like the smoking ban but the company I
was actually very unpopular when we did
it or he raised property taxes we had to
stabilize the the tax base ultimately
worked out but unpopular obviously
unpopular yeah so I remember sitting in
City Hall thinking like we're not gonna
really like this guy and his charm and
charisma because like our numbers are
terrible so look what could make him
different and you know even after being
around a few months I understood that he
was just a different kind of person and
but I've never since for again work the
politician like this he is completely
I was like what if we just make them the
most transparent ethical mayor in
history and we just own everything right
just if we compost something we take
credit for it if we failed we own up to
it any other politician if you proposed
that to them so we'll just like have
fired you on the spot so I made a list
of like 380 things they promised in the
old one campaign I just went through
like every transcript every newspaper
article every everything and I pitched
it to own he's like okay great idea and
then we went and did it and what
percentage of things had to you we had
we had probably done about a third of
them that's actually pretty huh not bad
we were we were probably working on
another third and then another third
nothing at all and we actually had to
change my mind category as well just
like because you know never were
government before their ideas in the
campaign and then once he got into the
city realize like okay it doesn't make
sense yeah that's fine this is my
biggest thing with politics is somehow
changing your mind when you get more
information is seen as a negative rather
than a positive it's the one thing I
just can't I'm like I can only have one
problem it's just it's the one that I
eat no matter how much people try to
explain to me why it is I still like
narrow but like that is the sign of
intelligence not to say is the hobgoblin
of little minds right yeah yeah it's
crazy for sure so my Bloomberg though is
obviously you know kind of the opposite
of all of that sure so yeah he was just
this sort of an incredible unique guy
that's really hard to to kind of compare
him to anyone else I'd I've learned that
lesson the hard way sometimes like Oh
what if we just sorted this person it
seems like Michael and we try this like
the answers they're never like Mike but
yeah and a part of the way that got them
it's usually the politics is one thing
government's another so I went and sat
down with every commissioner I said like
Ray Kelly like hey how would you at
least seventeen promises you like what
promises it turned out some of them we
was doing anyway that's how we kind of
had a very roughly you know done but a
lot of it was like oh okay I'll start
working on this or something big well
honor if I want to do that and I'm like
look if you wanna make an orchestra why
it's a bad idea I'll take it back to
Mike but if you just don't want to do it
that's okay but we're having a press
conference we're announcing the status
of every single one of these things so
Mike is gonna publicly announce that
you're bad at your job if you're
comfortable with that it's okay with me
sure turns out nobody was couple with
that yeah so amazingly people
to work so he was really really unique
but getting back to your question it's
critical right because at the end of the
day cities are neither inherently clean
safe and well-run nor inherently
dangerous and poorly run it's as good as
the management right and the reason why
New York City you know for a long time
it's been pretty solid is for all Rudy's
craziness right now when he was mayor he
was actually a pretty good man those
eight years and then Mike just governed
this completely businesslike nonpartisan
independent way that just no one's ever
done before right so yeah 20 years that
de Blasio is managing until I destroy a
lot of it but but they built up so much
talent and processes that made sense and
work that it's the city's been holding
on do you see can you've operated in all
levels of government right and now on
the regulatory and legal side you still
kind of touch a lot of that stuff do you
see a significant advantage for folks
who have business experience and operate
it from a management executive type
approach versus other approaches or is
that well more there's there section in
fact well there's some value in the
actual governance itself so Mike really
did try to treat say God might as much
as he could like a private enterprise
and it worked really well the track
record of really rich people running for
office and winning is pretty bad yeah
Mike one so in New York we don't realize
that because we had him but most of the
time when some CEO runs for office they
get killed they spend a ton of money
consultants sort of stuck all the money
out of their campaign and they get no
votes so why because running for office
is really hard and it's a totally
separate skill set from anything else a
separate skill set sorry from holding
office and Michael only one because a
911 you know all of a sudden this
incredibly terrible unprecedented thing
happens
everyone's mindset flips on a dime Rudy
sort of deified as this guy who did a
really good job and in the moment he
endorses Mike and all of a sudden people
said you know what I don't care about
partisanship I just want a confident
person and looking the the guy running
against with a mark greenie which is
like a total hack so you had a hack on
one side you had this sort of
billionaire you know it makes it more
obvious yeah and the only wall might
50,000 votes in the city of 8.6 million
people so it was really close
but he get out but if not for 911 we
lose by 25 points Wow
and then the real axe were you know a
function of his his performance as mayor
and I think at least the one that I ran
function of our campaign but but
nonetheless it's pretty rare so so in
all of these places cities can really
succeed they can really fail and it
really depends on the quality people you
put in and so in the last two elections
New York City is eight point six million
people they'll de Blasio in the
primaries and in those cases the
primaries really war the general
election he got three hundred twelve
thousand votes in 2013 two hundred
eighty two thousand votes in 2017
roughly four percent of the city's
population pick this guy and we get what
we asked for right
is it turn out that low yeah it really
is Wow
and that's and and you get really shitty
governance and really bad mayor's when
nobody bothers to show up and so that's
that's what happened and that's why I
like the Blasio who hates the job of
being mayor the near post reporter that
he spent you know many hours you spend
at City Hall on the month of May total
I'm gonna guess that he spent four hours
every other day so call let's give him
15 hours a week so we'll go with 60
hours say so if you subtract 53 from
that you'd be correct the whole [ __ ]
month I mean he's a little mom made I
saw that I was those I wanted you to go
as high as possible good point
he just doesn't doesn't like be in there
they don't like the job and it's you
know cuz the job is it's not a Java ID
lodge ideology it's a job about like you
know it's hard go trash and the water
and in streets and this it's hard and
you got to really care about operations
right yeah you don't good luck yet good
luck and that's what we're seeing right
now but lots of cities have that problem
on the flip side of Ceuta like Philly
which was really falling apart you had a
really good mayor like Rendell and he
was able to really help bring it back so
the good news is cities can get better
the bad news is they can get worse so if
you're a property owner here in New York
City it's really important to the mayor
because the value of that investment the
significantly impacted by the city's
overall quality of life yeah let's go
back to Chuck in Washington what uh what
was that experience like you know insane
brutal but a really good learning
experience Chuck is famous for having a
press conference every Sunday every
Sunday every Sunday no he has one every
other day the week too but on Sunday
it's his big one because he's right
people the local newscasts have like the
highest ratings of the week as people
are home and no one else is working so
you can kind of just dominate it so a
huge part of my offense I'm pretty smart
he's brilliant that's just ask him he
will tell you how smart he is so you
know sounds like other people yeah a
huge part of my job which is coming up
with like nonsense for every Sunday like
what was most ridiculous like I think we
did one about like the high price of
breakfast cereal I think we had
something about like windshield wiper
fluid we were always forming there's a
blue-ribbon Commission's which meant
nothing or one trick is we would send a
letter to some company protesting
something and you know Weiner you got
announced that you sent the letter yeah
and then they're out there on Sunday
right so it's a one-sided story but I
started noticing that the the response
from the people that we were going after
kept saying we never got the letter and
then it hit me the point of it was only
the press head so once press conference
over I kept forgetting to actually send
the letter I ended up having a post note
on my computer that said we remember to
send the latter so we just made up all
kinds of [ __ ] but actually not in a
weird way the job was sort of split into
for me because exactly a year into my
tenure there as well 9/11 happened so
then for a good six months the work the
work we did felt went from being like
pretty superfluous because Congress does
so little to really important in part
because chuck was securing lots of
federal aid to help me recover you know
in a part because people did need to see
their leaders and it really made a
difference in Chuck and his work ethic
really can't work that well because he
was willing to go to everything you know
be withheld one of the attention for
sure but he'll but at that moment what
he cared he genuinely cared he really
did and at that moment it was what the
city needed you know because of that I
saw Rudy in action this whole time and
like just showing leadership in a moment
like
is really really critical one of my my
favorite stories from 9/11 which I've
seen this horrible event but is uh and
there's video of it on YouTube is when
President Bush comes in deficits Ground
Zero and the video that's online is
basically you know he grabs a bullhorn
he's standing and he's about 15 feet
from him we did that okay so you
probably know the story even better than
then I read it which is he didn't plan
on doing that
no he said he was kind of just walking
around I was like oh these people need
someone to tell them like it's gonna be
okay
it was look I'm not a bush fan I'm
actually this point of local dependent I
hate both parties but I'm certainly not
a Republican and I thought that he was
incredible in that moment really I was
totally inspired and was screaming and
cheering and everything else you know he
jumps on top of the fire truck you know
I hear you and soon they're gonna hear
you and it was it was an incredible
moment you know and he really did at
that moment show so great leadership I
don't think he ended up being a great
president overall but it was electric I
think and even the Democrats there they
might lie about it but like everyone was
yeah well and it's also he said earlier
aid kind of all of the partisanship goes
away in those moments where people just
say hey look we're American yeah let
them happen very often actually given
the climate we have right now but that
was a moment where everyone just said
you know doesn't matter we just gotta
try to do the right for sure and then
how'd you end up in Chicago so kind of a
crazy story some that City Hall in New
York in New York working for Mike we had
just launched that whole campaign
promise thing and that my phone rings
and we're you know it's a bullpen in the
Bloomberg world right no one has an
office what he doesn't either he's just
in the middle desk and then we're all
and my office today is like that you
know the same thing and sag I know who
said had you ought to be the deputy
governor of Illinois I said what's a
deputy governor and why he called me
yeah who the [ __ ] are you right and so a
guy who now is named you're gonna know
it in Rob Blagojevich and had kind of
come out of nowhere to win the
governorship no one expected him to win
he didn't really have like a team yeah
because he just he was a congressman
which he's got very little staff
and he was a congressman yeah before
that he was congressman before that but
yeah curse never you know nine employees
whatever it not people of state had
seventeen I'll try to run this baby yeah
exactly
and so but what they understood about
him was they needed someone that was
young enough it'll be such a career
making job that you would put up with
all of his insanity I truly believe that
fraud had pled insanity at his trial
they would have to have given it to him
now the problem is crazy people don't
think they're crazy yeah so he never
played sanity lender for the fourteen
year jail sentence yeah
but they needed someone that liked I was
29 right so okay you're 29 and you get
to run all the operations the whole
budget legislation policy communications
for the fifth biggest state in the
country okay I'll put up with pretty
much anything for the opportunity to do
that and I did and it was an insane for
years because rod had a both highly
logical and illogical view of things
which is his job was to run for office
mm-hmm and he would do he did his job
effectively he won and he would
literally say I did my job and like he
wouldn't come to the office for three or
four months at a clip he had no interest
in governing where was he home he really
whatever that agoraphobia phrase meant I
would like to leave their home he has
that um interesting he would go for like
six day he was in great shape because
like six to eight mile runs every day
just a lot of stretching watch lot of
SportsCenter had three biographies
Napoleon but not a lot but those are
interesting combination to thinks yeah
he's I mean he's in some ways a
brilliant guy in some ways not but
what's the Kanye saying show me a genius
who's not a little crazy yeah right for
sure and intact we certainly understand
that but but he yeah he just like it
took me a few months to fit
had no interest like I'm the first
legislative session ends it has
typically four or five hundred bills in
recession and most of them are nonsense
like the official and fibular illinois'
the Frog or whatever like actually
matter for public policy and so you like
have the lawyers review it the budget
would have you at the policy people
review it as a recommendation the
protesters show up oh there's something
on I'm trying to meet with them to say
like okay what do you want to do in
these bills and he won't come to the
can I come to you and Cigna I'm reading
or whatever so funds like will do you
know what you want to do in these bills
I'm like I have my opinion it's like
alright just do that and then now is it
and then from there on out every bill
every dollar spent the state budget
every piece of policy pardons granting
them denying them whatever else like I
just did it because that was in any way
qualified I was 29 years old but there
was no one else to do it right that's
[ __ ] why it was not talking about the
pardons one of the things that I've
talked a number of people on everyone
from magnificat successful on is around
the criminal justice reform make sure
all the stuff and the one stat that
blows my mind is if you are up for
parole there is a number of studies that
show stupid facts like the closer you
are to lunch before the lunch hour the
less likely you are to be approved right
and so like you want the 9:00 a.m. slot
rather than the 11:30 slot right and
just human nature they want to get it
over with you know stupid stuff and
whatever up people's lives and jail
stuff what's it like being on the other
side where sure people are constantly
asking for pardons constantly and it's
look in a weird way it felt like even
more responsibility than say the budget
or legislation because if you let
someone out and they hurt somebody
that's really on you right the downside
yeah politically but also just morally
right like it weighed heavily on me so
basically I set up a policy and said if
you're a violent offender and your crime
was in the last that looks five years
seven years whatever it is you're still
in your jail sentence like no but we're
did it come back later if you're
non-violent okay then we're open to it
look generally speaking the world has
evolved in a way from justice reform
where I think people generally now think
that most non violent offenders probably
shouldn't be incarcerated in the first
place so that was how I try to divvy
things up and I didn't mind granting
pardons if someone clearly it was a
non-violent person and could get back
into society but I'd never want to take
the risk of someone getting hurt so it
kind of worked out International also
you know Illinois I don't think there's
somebody we still technically had the
death penalty at a time but we just put
a complete stay on executions and then
anybody who we could show those
any evidence at all DNA that they were
actually relative convicted you know we
were just releasing you know the the one
of the most fascinating aspects of
politics to me today is the interaction
between the actual political legislation
and kind of that whole process with the
law enforcement so you see in places
like Baltimore where you know the DHS
says look you guys can keep arresting
all these people for you know kind of
possession of small amounts of marijuana
I'm not prosecuting so I'm essentially
decriminalizing it without actually
changing the law yeah and you really
start to see where the power comes from
in terms of the legislation versus the
enforcement of those legislation and
it's just fascinating yeah I mean
oftentimes I think people who work in
politics especially if you work in the
legislature tend to think like okay we
passed this bill therefore we solve the
societal problem we pass this bill and
now there's some program that can try
and probably will fail but can at least
try to solve this problem right and off
what happens is then the people who were
executing it that really have most of
the power because how they actually go
about it really determines what doesn't
doesn't happen like if you all the time
people come to me and say I want to run
for congressman or for City Council
whatever it is and my answer is always
like if you go work in the executive
branch like the average like staffer in
the mayor's office is much more powerful
than like any almost any City Council
member right because they're they take
in the night the power to do everything
with it allocate money choose how things
are enforced not enforce whatever it is
like the realities you don't need to run
for office to have an impact in
government in some ways that's the worst
way to having a battle yeah that makes
sense
what was your take when all the stuff
was Roberts going down I mean so the way
that I kind of ended it with him was it
was towards Lee as 2006 mm-hmm so I've
been there for three plus years three
and a half years at this point and to
his credit he never ever like did
anything illegal around me until he
slipped up once
so rahm emanuel at the time was a
congressman from chicago then later
became the mayor of chicago had a let
axilla t in this district and I guess
rod had promised him two million dollars
in state money to help fix other
facility that's pretty normal stuff from
a fine
so and that's more of hey there's a
problem I have
yeah discretionary budget exactly and
that that's just normal but there were a
few things not my portfolio on one of
them were grants which later it's
because turns out they wanted he used us
for their own purposes but so ROM calls
me and if you're watching entourage yes
so Ari who's his brother in real life
but he's wrong to you every called it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you hangs up yells screams
curses some more and if you only heard
one call you back well I got really mad
not fine I used to like put him on
speakerphone and buy people in so I can
listen to it like it's a show so Ron's
going crazy on me about this thing I
don't know he's talking about right I'm
like when he finally stopped yelling cuz
like let me look into this I'll call you
back so that night I'm on the phone with
the Gloria [ __ ] and I just said hey by
the way I don't even know if this thing
is but Ron's really upset you know do
you want me just to make sure the money
gets dispersed I did not change early
heart-earth of two calls he's like no
Ari who's his brother our Emmanuel is
this chairman of endeavor owes me a fund
raiser and they're not getting that
grand till I got my fundraiser I said
you can't really link these things wants
politics one's government yep he said
you tell them what my fundraiser
and I was like okay that's clearly
illegal so I called our ethics counsel
and reported it and said you better put
a stop to it
and they did the fundraiser had never
happened the grant was given but I ended
up testifying in both of Rods corruption
trials - what was he was charged with
Health extortion congressman Manuel and
in that situation when that goes down
let's say that you had reported it what
I want to really understand it's like
the government oversight so these ethics
committees and stuff right they're all
there and I think there's like a false
sense of security and that like hey
there's a committee right my guess is
they don't get used nearly as much they
probably should be but when they do it
can it be preventive or is it always
kind of retro actively and and they're
going in enforcing the preventative is
usually like ethics training and trying
to teach people the right rules
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't
in this case it was preventative in the
sense that I was we were able to get
ahead of it and make sure that it didn't
happen yeah but more because our general
counsel was gonna build
was a really talented guy who could
figure out how to do that so ultimately
it worked in that case but once that
happened might kind of relationship with
rob was basically over and I left a few
months later yeah and to me you know it
is first time I've heard kind of the
details of it right but a lot of what's
going on right now in politics with
Trump and Biden and Ukraine and all this
crazy [ __ ] what I think for the like
layman who's never worked in government
frankly doesn't have a huge interest in
understanding how it works but when you
see this stuff it's hard to tell what is
kind of par for the course right of just
like hey we're negotiating vs. owner you
stepped over the bounds and like
actually by the law for sure or even
Biden right so let's just first stake of
Oregon stipulate that Biden didn't do
anything corrupt in terms of trying to
fire the prosecutor in the Ukraine hmm
no sorry Matt Joe by Joe Biden he's kind
of deadbeat kid still got six hundred
grand for being on the board of this
company that really he obviously had no
specific knowledge about how but because
his dad was vice president right so
there's this inherent soft corruption
that exists and you know I'm I'm for
anyone but Trump but nonetheless you
know that I think people in the system
just feel entitled to write Bernie
Sanders kid without a hundred grands
runs on Public Policy Institute funded
by the state of Vermont the Clintons are
you know the most sort of entitled in
all that Trump is sort of in a whole
different level of corruption but like
but ultimately I think where politicians
in Washington doesn't get is yeah there
might be legal lines but all but most
people don't get to like leverage their
their dad's power to get a whole lot of
money right I'd only Biden is gonna
survive this the two that throw me all
time and I say they seemed common sense
to me but again I'm coming at it you
know not nearly as much experience as
you is one if you are elected you cannot
legislate on topics that pertain to the
industry that funded your campaign so a
big farmer puts you in you know
essentially by funding your campaign you
shouldn't be a lot of legislate on big
pharma issues right right it probably
solves some of the problem
yeah and the second thing is this like
legal it's not really insider trading
right but basically the ability to buy
and sell stocks based on so legislation
and for years and years and years it was
not illegal for members of Congress and
actually trade stocks based on their own
information from Congress and they
finally they realized like okay so now
they can't do it now they can't do and
there's a congressman Chris Collins from
Buffalo who was indicted a few weeks ago
maybe a widow and resigned for taking
knowledge he has accomplishment yeah
making stock because the the and I
forget who it was it may have been Matt
Levine I may get it wrong but somebody
was basically saying like so take that
similar type of framework right and go
toes so Amazon it's gonna bring HQ to to
New York and you know if you know that
they're going to pick New York or you're
inside at the local government and you
start issuing permits and doing all
stuff and somehow that information is
used for somebody to go buy real estate
and then also the real state's gonna get
jacked up excetera
is that illegal is it not is it just
unethical but you know it's legal you
know you get into all these weird you
flex it ease and and here's the thing
government and politics like everything
else in life has a lot of gray right
most things are not like I got lucky at
the time that right ask you something
illegal it was pretty black and white
like no this is stupid
so so it was clear I mean don't do this
right but the reality is like that's
more the exception the norm is something
where it's like okay these people are
donors to your campaign they endorsed
this thing this is this policy therefore
that they want to see happen and you
want to make them happy but maybe you
also believe that thing too so here's
that pay-to-play corruption or is that
just ideologies that are compatible with
each other like this stuff is really
super implicated and in fact it has
gotten and the last couple years harder
to convict public officials of
corruption because the Supreme Court
said if something is gray you can't
really do it so for example in 2016 I
launched it what ended up being totally
failed campaign to get the Blasio out of
office
Oh interesting I was of this view and
I'm biased I was my skin paint manager
and all that so like I'm not objective
in any way but if you owned and he
reminded me a lot of rock right which
was he's incredibly lazy and incredibly
corrupt the Blasio's under 7 7 separate
federal criminal investigations I'm all
for basically bribes in one form or
another really yeah all for basically
you know he that people give him money
and then the public policy they want
that all of a sudden became theirs and
I took the legal standard that was used
under pacaya vich and said it's there
seven of these things like one of them's
gonna hit he's gonna get indicted and
then I'll put someone else and I didn't
even that's a care who it was I just
wanted someone who was like work hard
and at the home yeah not be stealing
right and the reason I lost is the DEA
and the US Attorney stood up one day it
was February of 2017 and they said we
believe that de Blasio broke the letter
of law and the spirit of law we don't
have enough hard evidence to bring
charges and I put out a statement in an
hour later saying I respect it they did
their investigation and if there's no
indictment I don't have I'm not gonna
attract the top-tier candidate into the
race so he's gonna get reelected yep but
it was really based on the fact that in
and where I [ __ ] up was I took the
legal standard used in blue Koya veg and
in the intervening couple of years there
wasn't that much time this case McDonald
got handed down by supreme court now I
was aware of it but I didn't really
factor it in enough and to the standard
Cain's and where's the for McDonald they
clear of brought charges against the
Blasio and know they were gonna win post
without like oh we might not win Diana
sitting Mears it's a big deal right and
so I've miscalculated that and as a
result I lost campaign yeah I mean look
at it is what it is but at the same time
it's just facts yeah look I I did it for
the right reasons I just you know the
largest independent spender and they're
still in 2017 election there's a lot of
my pocket and you know tried to do what
I thought was right yeah but I got it
wrong uber how'd you so it you know
how'd you meet Travis yeah so it's a
weird story no I love people who start
off with it's a weird story because it's
a good story things out so I'm so after
the sort of the Bloomberg campaign in a
nine
I run the campaign we win and I start my
first company it's a consulting firm
that runs campaigns for big companies so
okay Walmart was one of our first
clients and the kind of thing were they
baked okay we want to build a store in
downtown Boston New York whatever it is
and there's union issues there's zoning
issues there's community issues it was
on me to figure out how to overcome all
those and make it happen and so I'm
sitting in a Walmart meeting it's early
2011 and a friend of mine calls got from
the Bloomberg world and said hey there's
this guy with a small transportation
startup he said
regulatory problems used to may favor
and talk to him and I was like yes sure
why not and two hours later I'm on the
phone with Travis I don't know who or
what he is right it's a tiny little
company it's a tiny little startup and
we're talking about it I'm thinking okay
this is actually pretty interesting
because this guy is taking a really
shitty industry in taxi and wants to
blow it up and what is he saying on the
phone that makes you think it's
interesting he's on you like data is he
telling you his vision he tell me his
vision what he said to me and I remember
this so clearly is he said one day no
one will on a car they will all drive
themselves and you'll get them by
pressing a button and the truth is for
whatever challenges and problems he's
had he's going to be right and there's
no one in the world that came closer to
bringing that to reality than him that's
pretty [ __ ] impressive that was his
views early 2011 and so much you know
what all right this sounds interesting
and look it was my company I could do
whatever I want I don't partners or
investors or anything like that so I
gotta [ __ ] he's like they calls back
hey I can't afford your feet would you
take equity I don't know what I could he
meant right I had no idea now it's like
okay and yeah that ended up being the
best decision I've ever made
what did he give you next ended up with
a couple of hundred thousand dollars in
series a equity that turned out to be
like it at one point I was like up like
250 X now the stock has fallen so I'll
probably settle out more like 150 175 X
butBut pretty good return yeah so yeah
and and now it's right so I don't even
need to know what the cost what the
original was it up 150 X is pretty good
yeah and so but what we did that was
really interesting and fun and I think
formed the basis for how kind of texts
are dealing politics is yeah we were
this little company in taxi was this big
cartel I mean now you know if ever
thinks of that the other way around but
we couldn't compete with them on
lobbying or campaign contributions or
all the normal ways the game is played
right alright so before we go and is
because I wanna I want to talk about
like the hand-to-hand combat you guys
digs I've heard wild stories and I got
the source of truth here now so what was
the challenge that he was facing cuz it
was specifically coming into New York it
was near pretty to be clear so he'd only
they were only in San Francisco at that
point okay and he'd had that problem
there he had had the problem there yet
we had it in every single market in the
country okay which is the local taxi
industry did not want competition and
they were politically savvy and
influential enough to lean on the local
politicians to say shut these guys down
they're violating the law and in every
single city that I can recall we got a
cease and desist letter saying you have
to stop and the thing that Travis did
that was so brilliant two things one is
to his card he's like [ __ ] it we're
trying to go in anyway and push as far
as we can and what he understood is if
you let the genie out of the bottle
right think about the first time you
used uber now you're annoyed because
it's suppose we four minutes take seven
minutes but that you imagine just match
is the most incredible thing ever and by
everyone list in this podcast no matter
how annoyed you are with your uber right
now it was magical and it wasn't just
one piece like I pressed a bun it was
two pressing the button it was getting
in the car it was when not having to pay
when you get out of the car like the
whole floor is magic the whole seamless
experience so what we knew was if we
could show that to people and the
juxtaposition was this like shitty tax
experiences there's dirty and they're
mean to you and it smells bad and you
know that they're screwing you it's all
wrong that we could maybe get our
customers to just be our advocates
politically right this was the big bet
that Travis had the inside around which
was I think what we're doing is so
special that people will fight for it
and then we had the ability through the
app to reach all of our customers and
say here's the issue it started an in DC
least the City Council at the best of
taxi putting a bill that would have
totally wiped Hoover out of the out of
the market and you know we had lobbyists
we were doing the normal stuff but I
knew we couldn't couldn't compete on
those grounds and we we did a test from
Travis put out an email to every
customer DC area and said hey you're so
we are here's what we're trying to do
it's a binary thing either either we
survive or we don't if you like what
we're doing can you please email your
councilmember and we just gave well
let's do everyone's email adresses we
wasn't even like automated now if I
press a button and it automatically like
I think was pretty man analog and like
in three days 50,000 people holy [ __ ]
emailed their council members the
bad bill was defeated unanimously the
sponsor the bad bill voted against her
own bill we wrote a second new bill that
was passed unanimously and that was the
basis for ended up being how
ride-sharing was legalized in every
market in the US which is we were
consistently able to mobilize our
customers and ended up overtime then a
couple of million people tweeted email
texted in some way used technology to
tell their local officials I want to be
able to do this thing and the reality of
what politics works and stop if this
gets boring but I don't go so you're a
city council member right hmm your only
goal is reelection you don't give a [ __ ]
about anything else
so you need money for your campaign so
for as long as you can do the bidding of
your donors and not have any political
problems as a result you're gonna do
that that's the smart politics but like
in a typical New York City Council race
turnout too tiny 15 20,000 people
despite how big the city itself is if
all of a sudden that number people from
your district your emailing and texting
and calling you and saying like I want
this thing you're like all right we'll
[ __ ] taxi because like I'm they're gonna
vote me out of office if I if I do this
so all right you got what you want like
politicians make incredibly rational
logical decisions based on
self-preservation every single turn and
if you understand that that's the basis
for all of their decisions then it's not
as hard to sort of get them to make the
decisions you want them to make you know
if you can prove that hey if you do what
I want you get reelected and if you
don't do what I want you won't realize
yeah and with rubra we were able to
amass enough numbers that they felt that
and as a result we want I remember in
New York at one point people would open
the app and there was no cars I feeling
with that net was called that option
what de Blasio de Blasio oh yeah it was
right yeah and then basically was like
if de Blasio gets his way this is what
ever will be right and there's no
[ __ ] cars and good luck uh-huh and
people were pissed pissed yeah and like
you know same thing in a matter of I
remember I'm sitting in this actually
like literally I I'll plug my book he
wrote a book about a year ago called The
Fixer and it's a memoir about takun
Paulo that's a badass name thank you my
publish trash we thought of it not me
but you take credit for your book I
wrote
and this is the start of the book which
is I'm sitting in the Dallas Airport
it's like a random Tuesday in June and
I'm not even working with uber at this
point it's a year they've at that point
they've set up their operation you know
I'm just friends of Travis and Travis
calls me and said did you see what the
Blasio did I'm like no I'm not getting
stuck with like raining my flights
canceled oh my god now what other crazy
[ __ ] did he do right
and he said check it out and call me
back so I googled it I called him back
and he's like how bad is it so Mike it's
really bad because if the mayor and the
Speaker of the City Council both want
something to happen historically we
couldn't find that a single example in
the history of New York City were it had
not happened right Wow and he's like
well you got to kill this thing and I
was like I think I own [ __ ] now and
then I just said listen how much can I
spend and what is there anything I can't
do and to his credit I said whatever you
need wherever you want to do it's just
blanket approval on anything you want
and so I get on if I get on a flight
stand by I'm like blastro by the
bathroom middle seat but my brains just
churning on this thing and like
literally kind of a half way over like
the Ozarks whatever it hits me like you
know the Blasio prides himself on being
like this great progressive icon and
he's a symbol of justice and equality
and like what if we tacked him from the
left
everyone always attacked him from the
right he's gonna make crime go up he's
an T business he's an T cop whatever it
is but what if we said that this is a
racist anti-immigrant program and we
basically say the total hypocrite he's
really not woke he ran the whole
campaign through that so we had all
these drivers who were immigrants saying
why is taking away my livelihood and
because you know I think anyone of any
person of color listen to this podcast
knows that taxis have this terrible
history of just passing people by not
available if you're black or brown so
that's like very academically proven no
black it's indisputable
so we had lots of african-american and
Latino customers saying like there's
only I can get home right this won't
take me and we were able to basically
combine that with all the grass roots
through the app and built so much
pressure that we kept picking off
council member a council member council
member we're running millions of dollars
of TV ads we've got every feasible form
of communication going and we're just
beating the living [ __ ] out of them
and then eventually enough Council
members want the speaker and just like
we're not taking this hit for you guys
yeah and we call okay can you meet with
the speaker and we make this long list
but like things we could give right like
here are the concessions we can live
with so the head of Josh Moore who's the
GM when you're sued Josh when people go
we keep me out of it because it's like
I'm the boogeyman that they can sell if
we don't get this done we're gonna stick
him on you again and I'm waiting waiting
waiting and then get taxed and so we're
good what do you mean it's like they
gave up and I'm like so what do we keep
is like nothing like what do you mean
nothing he said they just want to take
down a TV ads I'm like done cost me a
million Doc's week I can do that
they just wanted to go away yeah that
was it I'm [ __ ] crazy so it was great
but was also so important is that
because New York City is the medium
capital of the world that was seen in
Europe and Asia of South America so it
had a chilling effect on bad legislation
everywhere because every other mayor in
the world salt we get to the mayor of
New York City I don't want ya if you can
do it to him you definitely can do it to
me right what um before I forget where
can people get the book Oh
Amazon or Barnes & Noble or anything
like that called The Fixer is published
by by Random House came out in September
of 2018 it's basically all stories like
we've been talking about both kind of
the first half of my life was politics
on second half is kind of uber and then
into you know the the 20 startups I've
invested in all these campaigns we've
run whether it's on fantasy sports or
scooters or insurance or anything else
got it while we're on the topic of uber
and Travis talked us through
he obviously gets completely blindsided
kisses his whole experience from your
seat being friends with him having seen
kind of his resolve and fairly
determination going up against you know
what to me would be insurmountable oh
it's time and time and time again not
only building a company but regulations
etc kind of what was your whole take on
the situation that that he went through
so you know look he's the only person
that I know that could have achieved
what he achieved right and the problem
is people or two sides of the same coin
so in order to be ruthless and tough
enough to face down and break a cartel a
car color by the way like like at like a
legit cartoon this is this isn't like oh
those guys are left
legs yeah this is real right this guns
involved and [ __ ] you know to be tough
enough you're probably not also gonna be
the softest most like empathetic person
in other parts of your life right and so
where he fell short is he had the sort
of consuming ambition and pursued it
with just incredible relentlessness and
he was really good at innovating but you
know as the company went from a scrappy
started to a big company in terms of
workplace culture it didn't really occur
to him I think in you know I'm not sure
he would agree with this but I would say
I don't think it really occurred to him
that you had sort of changed the nature
of the workplace and the culture as
you're growing for internal reasons not
just things that are related to the ROI
one way or another yeah and so that's
where I think he fell flat I think also
in my experience with him he knew what
he didn't know and so if we said hey
this is when he's beyond politics he
would usually agree Sutton I'm not sure
that that was true across the board so
it sounds like is that the HR people
were so afraid to tell him bad news and
it's his fault for creating an
environment where people are afraid to
tell him bad news but by that happening
bad [ __ ] was happening he wasn't doing
the bad things but he also wasn't
stopping it because they weren't even
want to tell him about it
and ultimately you fear the CEO you own
it you know what ended up being kind of
really of a problem for uber
shareholders including me is the board
was so desperate to stop being attacked
right because they were getting hit by
name on all these different podcast and
everything else that the guy they
appointed they said let's get a guy who
just to take the temperature down and
they did and Dora
you know Kane was the CEO of Expedia
he'd be greater running Johnson &
Johnson he regretted running the US
Department of Commerce he could run
Princeton University he's a terrific
manager not an innovator in any way
shape or form and what they forgot about
is the market for a tech company wants
an innovator right no one's betting on
uber because if it's cashflow today it
loses money you're betting on the future
and you have to believe this is the guy
that's gonna say all cars will drive
themselves and we'll get it by pressing
a button and everything else and when
you lose all faith in the company's
ability to innovate the stock goes down
and we're down 40% since the IPO in May
it is pretty crazy how
Bhalla opposed those two things are
right it's almost like the the
perspective of the company and and the
kind of you know woke miss of society
today and expectations and things that
are looking frankly very valid concerns
about a business and culture etc can be
the opposite of the innovator and cash
flows etcetera now before everyone
freaks out on Twitter those two things
don't have to always be opposite right
there are people who get them right but
the people who are really good at one
extreme are usually not good at both
extremes so I was it's interesting so
you you can look at this and I think we
work in in some ways or Tesla or
examples at all so you could look at
which is you can't if you're a VC right
you can't not invest in the slightly
crazy genius because that's where the
sort of really radical good stuff tends
to happen right so you don't want to
pass up a Travis kalanick or Neela
you're lost at the same time the game
planner like hate will just switch that
person out with a good manager for the
IPO doesn't work as we saw with uber
right so you need to invest in these
people that are kind of crazy you need
to keep innovating but at the same time
you need to understand where they're
gonna go wrong and put some controls in
place and I think one of the things that
the VC world as a whole is really guilty
is of is that everybody wants to win the
deal everybody wants to get an
allocation and the easiest way to do is
to tell the founder whatever they want
to hear so you're gonna have dual class
voting chairs no problem you determine
the line of succession for the next
hundred years no problem if you die if
you die you can you're you're so in
control yeah right if you want to
corporate jet no problem and when people
never hear no and they get lot of
control they lose all perspective
completely and it's really incumbent
upon all of us to say yes we're
competing with each other yes you know
we want to win the deal but if we don't
insist on some level of governance and
standards this is gonna keep happening
time and time again I think we're at a
moment now especially the implosion if
we work that people are at least
understanding this whether people
actually act on it I don't know right
look I know that we turned down a deal a
couple months ago because the fact we
were gonna put that into our machine we
were about to do it and then
that the structure that she showed us
was so out of control that when we
objected to it should okay no problem
we'll switch it we were like you know
what if this is your mindset at the seed
you know then it was like at the Bailey
proceeded of like what are you gonna be
like by the beard see I forget it we're
out but you know oftentimes you overlook
that stuff and that's relief to this
yeah for sure you start with uber and
you took equity obviously for their
services you since have raised funds and
now kind of you continue to do a lot of
the the lobbying and servicing and
campaigns etc but you also have a fun
how do you get is definitely weird
unique different for better or for worse
which is we're the only venture fund
that I'm aware of that invests at the
intersection of politics and technology
that's like the antithesis of almost
every resident totally which is why
raising fund law was so hard but you
know we look for are the same things
that enter VC we care about the TAM and
the founder and then on tech and the
vision but in the other thing that we
really like is is there some sort of big
gating political regulatory issue that
if it's solved can really unlock growth
and if it's not can really hinder growth
and if so do we think we can solve it if
the answer is yes and yes
that's where we wanted to play capital
so we invested in bird of the series a
and then ran campaigns to legalize
electric scooters we invested in
lemonade the series a and then ran
campaigns against insurance industry to
get them their licenses in every state
invested in fanned or then ran two
campaigns 23 state to legalize fantasy
sports and things like that where we say
is there some area where our particular
expertise is really unique and that a
lets us make hopefully good choices but
be it's a steel flow and access because
if you're a founder and you want our
help I've got to have investment rights
you know if I don't have them I'm not
gonna work with you
look I'm super tapped into a lot of
venture capital stuff as somebody said
to me I need someone to solve regulatory
problem you guys are the probably the
only one that I wrecked now we have him
and I look I got really lucky in that
like a lot of things broke right in the
sense that typically people who start
with the kind of political tilting firm
that I did you sell it to like there are
these big holes in couple of WPP or omni
I just didn't want to work for anybody
else so I was like I'm not gonna sell
gave me the probably best friend's
breath I had the money that I made from
uber so I had financial independence I'm
pretty risk friendly you know my two
main kind of credentials were Mike
Bloomberg and uber right so those were
pretty good and to all of that and and
in my consulting business was profitable
enough that I could basically say I'm
gonna build out this huge infrastructure
to run all its campaigns to solve these
problems for startups and that's gonna
cost me a lot of money but I'll get it
back either on equity or in deal flow of
and it will ultimately make me a lot
more money all of those things came
together in a weird way to let me do
this so right now we're doing one to do
it
will someone copy us you have course you
know more power to yeah but but it's
also you know you can't stumble into it
right tomorrow if I said hey I like that
strategy I'm gonna go pursue that
strategy I can't go do it right I don't
have the skillset and the experience and
off the connections exactly the DNA so
injuries and hardwoods for example set
up a public policy group and brilliant
people the the general counsel Facebook
people from ENS a really talented but
you know it was the starting point was
venture intact not politics and most
tech regulation really happens to be
knispel level the state level and
street-fighting
you know isn't getting in there and just
you know bloodying up a regulator or
city council member and if that's not
you if you don't love that i love that
[ __ ] yeah it's a hand-to-hand combat of
literally we're going we're gonna go
meet with the would you say the House
Speaker here's our list of demands and
walking out and all they want us to get
stop the [ __ ] idea exactly so if you
like that stuff it's really fun hard but
really fun if that's not your DNA it's
really hard to win these campaigns for
sure let's talk a little bit because
you're doing a lot of the investing
stuff you've got to things around
blockchain crypto coin acceptor they
don't talk about first let's go to just
Bitcoin and gotta up the crypto
investing you've done yeah just walk us
through so have you done this yeah so
we're investors out of the fund in coin
base circle and Google radar relay which
is it did you know that and then
separately from that on the consulting
side we do some work with tezo's we
worked on this crazy project to create
the first-ever sovereign crypto currency
for the Marshall Islands oh yeah
yeah it was didn't happen but it was it
was conceptually really interesting I
was like I want to be involved in this
thing
you take tokens with a the other team
worth nothing but yes I did so but my
here's my thesis and I don't think it's
different than most people in this
podcast which is so I'm not a traitor
and I don't buy or sell any particular
currency because I have no ability to
know what's going up or down since there
are people that had that skill set god
bless him not me yeah but what I saw in
politics is the world has changed people
don't have faith institutions the way
they used to but that can be the
government the media the church higher
ed you know Wall Street but across the
board there's just a lack of faith in
central institutions and when there's a
vacuum of faith it's got to go somewhere
right and one place that it goes is
Bitcoin in theory I mean the notion of
hey we don't really trust a central
government to set monetary policy in a
way that's not totally rigged we'd
rather take our own chances with
ourselves and self govern and I think
that that makes sense it is that most of
the population know but is it 5% 10% 15%
yeah and like that's pretty big great
that's one we're at 1% now most likely
and so I mean it's and I think it's I
think it can get much bigger and so if
you believe that the reason why all of
our investments have been on the
exchange side is whether it goes up or
down if you believe that people have
this lack of faith institutions and that
they would rather instead you know finer
alternative way to trade their money and
invest their money if you're making
money on the trade regardless right
because you're just processing it one
way or the other to me that's a good
business to be in so we focus mainly on
exchanges so far but we you know it's
it's a fascinating world so that's been
half of it and the other half of it and
this will now I think make some sense
give them this conference we've had
which is so because I took my fee no
burn equity I like I said you like the
Facebook mural guy so I now have Todd's
philanthropy he's because well what will
the story so just so people get the
reference it is there's a guy who
painted a mural at Facebook and he
walked away they paid him in equity and
I think it ended up being worth 200
million dollars which is more than I
made together
but I made enough and you and you did
real work yeah any pie you enjoyed what
he was doing right but but it wasn't a
street fighting with the mayor of New
York I like that [ __ ] but um but so the
thing I learned in politics and we
talked about this is every policy output
is the result of a political input if
you accept the fact that 99.9% of
politicians are desperately unsecure
self-loathing people that can't live out
the validation of holding office then
you understand that every decision they
make is solely based on re-election
asking them to go without that job
without the validation feeling like
there's somebody feeling relevant it's
like asking you or me to go out oxygen
they can't do it yes if use it the truck
Schumer truck you got a choice tomorrow
you can die or you can live but no one
will ever utter your name again he would
honestly say like what's the difference
right and he couldn't wouldn't
understand the difference right so they
have to have that so expecting them to
make choices in their votes or their
policies they're gonna lose them the
next election he's unrealistic so if you
want to change the outputs you gotta
change the inputs and the questions what
are the inputs the inputs are votes and
because of gerrymandering the reality is
almost every election in this country's
decided in the primary not in the
general explains your the gerrymandering
is is a practice that's awful but legal
where both parties depending on who's in
power in particular state draws the
legislative districts and they draw them
in ways to literally like go block by
block to make sure that only a
Republican can win in that seat or only
a Democrat and both parties are equally
guilty of it both parties say they're
better than the other but the realities
are both totally do into both they're
both corrupt but as a result so they're
like 435 seats in the house
380 390 are decided in the primary and
then either were mean handful general
election and just to kind of drill down
on what you're talking about a loophole
the map and they draw a line and they
say hey this you know this section or
this question this street this guy's
house I mean it runs in these crazy
crazy way when you look at the maps it's
not like they drew you know like New
York City Street grid you know they put
it's literally why does it run up and
this really long sliver go on there's a
district if you don't york's the
geography that one's from coney island
all the way through the Upper West Side
it's Jerry Nadler seat that's insane
right that's a really long way but it's
this long long sliver of very left-wing
vote yeah all the way up right and so
because of that where the real elections
happen is the primary most of time not
the general election you don't have to
turn out as in primaries less than ten
percent of population is about 15 they
so so what happens is the usually the
hardest core either left-wing or
right-wing people are the ones who care
enough to go vote in the primary so if
you are any kind of politician you're
saying this is who I got to make happy
right so like when the politicians and
queens kicked out Amazon while I would
argue was terrible to say that they did
it they were right and that the people
who actually show up and vote in their
primary hate Amazon and politically it
was the logical choice or you know
you're a Republican congressman from
Florida and just as a gerrymander
turnout is 12 percent in your primary
you probably know than assault weapon
ban makes sense right you don't people
walk around your district with an ak-47
but if the NRA is half at 12%
you're never gonna vote for it because
you're just giving up your seat so then
it becomes but what after net worth 60%
and when that hit me was one we're doing
all the uber stuff and all of a sudden
billions of people who never vote in
primaries were all of a sudden engaging
politically it's like oh time that
everyone's apathetic that we make it too
hard right make it too hard and it's
also really hard to understand what
they're doing right right right yeah
it's like I have to physically drive to
a voting center like busily [ __ ] that I
know people it doesn't happen right I
mean the reason why it was the system
was created two hundred and fifty years
ago from agrarian society we vote on
Tuesdays cuz that's what made sense
sense for the farmers from the 1700s
right and they've kept it that way
because the people in power that's how
they have power so the only two things
that matter are kind of ideological
primary voters or groups with enough
money to kind of move and shape votes
within primaries so that's who has all
the power
so if only the most radical on each side
are the only things that have the inputs
that matter of course we can't be able
to pass legislation on climate change
for guns or immigration or healthcare
education or anything else because that
seventy percent that basically agrees on
most stuff you know with
differences they don't participate which
means they don't count and so the
question I asked was could we find a way
to get turnout from twelve fifteen
percent to sixty seventy percent and
then when blockchain came along all of a
sudden were like holy [ __ ] the answer
might be yes because you know we knew
from uber that people would engage but
obviously the way that we were doing it
was not secure we were just said Senate
tax entity now it was fine for what we
were doing right
voting is a more complicated process but
blockchain is everyone listen to the
podcast definitely knows obviously it's
a lot lot lot harder to hack and creates
a permanent record and you know if
anything has been changed right away and
so the notion the question was can we
start running elections over the
blockchain
and a lot of people to vote that way
from their phone so we started in state
of West Virginia a employee of mine her
mom it have to be the u.s. senator from
there so I called her and said hey any
ideas and someone who might want to try
this idea and the Secretary of State
there and Mac Warner its military guy
all forms kids in the military and it's
very hard to vote during military like
you know your mailing your ballot from
Kandahar that shows up come both later I
guess throw in the trash right so I was
literally in Iraq when the 2008 election
happened yeah and I remember 90 plus
percent of the guys didn't vote right
and just cuz it was too hard doesn't
matter risking your life to protect all
right to vote literally right so so my
view was let me start with the hardest
thing to object to which is who could
object to make it easier for soldiers to
vote right and Mac agreed and so the
state of West Virginia to their credit
said hey let's give this thing a try
I paid for the states cost to administer
the election out of my foundation so
that it would mean taxpayer expense and
then we put up with all the procurement
stuff and RFPs and all that other stuff
I don't invest in the companies that are
doing this cuz I want to really not care
who wins I just want to see it happen at
the moment the leading companies called
votes a block chain company out of
Boston vo ATC and the way it works is
they verify you you take a video of your
face and that gets matched up against
your ID for face recognition recognition
scan then your biometric fingerprint
once those two things are verified then
the app is like any a pic the batch
reporting for the officer game or
whatever it is but transmitted over the
blockchain it's on a private ledger and
then when it hits the Secretary of
State's office they print out a paper
copy the ballot so that it can be all
audited and we did it once Virginia the
you know multiple audits were done I've
got a team of former FBI cyber agents
who work for me now because I need this
stuff to work although I didn't do me
any good and they're auditing it and the
National Cyber Security Center is
auditing it it worked and then the city
of Denver did it this past spring would
they do it for military Utah County
different military was actually what
when is this gonna run next week when
next week you tell me when you want it
well so on I think we're good so on
Monday we have a big announcement okay
we'll make this go after Monday yeah so
so you're listening to this and it's
already been released this is the first
time I've said this publicly Utah is now
allowing people with disabilities to
also vote on their phone over blockchain
oh because if you're blind if I hadn't
really thought about it - it came up
it's like it's a penis for us to vote
imagine you're blind you had to get
there and then you got our trust of the
person who's helping you is actually
recording the both the way you want for
all you know their motive the opposite
or who they walking right horrible so
you try to network if you're blind on
your phone you they have different
devices that have Braille and things
like that we'd really thought about it
either but apparently we started talking
to advocate for the Bartlett no smart
phones like the greatest thing ever to
happen yeah we would love Phil to vote
this way so blind deaf oh there's a
basically a smart computer with Braille
where I can engage with it and it thinks
for me and I can ensure exactly what
it's doing yeah yeah so Utah will become
the first jurisdiction to allow another
demographic to do it look my strategy's
kind of obvious which is I'm starting
with all the unobjectionable groups and
trying to work my way into the middle
we're also gonna announce next week a
couple of counties in other states will
be up to five different jurisdictions
doing it in each case you know we're
doing three things one is we're
convincing election officials to give it
a try and then I'm paying for all the
costs of administering elections which I
can do for a why can't do indefinitely
but I made enough money that can do it
for a while
we are working with and this ones that
were they want to call the podcast quite
frankly is blockchain startups if you're
interested in doing this we will give
you a lot of the expertise you need as
to how you deal with voting how are you
doing the politicians we do a lot of the
block and tackling we're providing their
resources if somebody is interested in
this how these go to mobile voting org
this contact sheet on there and if
you're interested we actively are
constantly talking to different watching
companies because we want to work with
you can this solution be built by the
government or does have to be private
enterprise that's a good question
could it yes of course it could and
we've had conversations with DARPA about
it my faith having run a government my
faith tends to be more private
enterprise what I would like to see is
five or six companies competing with
each other and constantly in about
trying to innovate the other doing this
type of work so that that's what I'd
like to if that can happen you know I've
also thought about do I just kind of
incubated myself and kind of create an
open API I'm willing to do that if I
need to but I would rather see private
enterprise do that that's just a better
way to go yeah how long till you think
we can get to a presidential election in
the United States done with Mobile
voting yeah so look some next year I'm
confident there will be some votes in
the presidential record over blockchain
oh you think so well all the votes so
far they're real votes so yeah but
they're state so close last West
Virginia was senator governor okay
Denver was mayor yeah it's our City
Council just whatever is on the ballot
right it could be City Council could be
President so the stuff whatever we do
next year it's gonna be president by and
large that's awesome 2028 sort of my
internal just in my head deadline of
like one I want that every single person
can just do this thing I'd love to get
it done faster the other time when I use
my daughter's 13 and so I she'll be
voting age in five years what do I need
to do in the next five years that when
the powers that be say to her no no you
can't do this it's not safe she could
say [ __ ] it's been proven 50 times
over and they've done all these places
all these people have tried and you just
don't want me to do it this yeah what do
you think the impact is if there is
mobile voting I mean I believe that
fundamentally it saves the republic I
don't right now if you look at the state
of Washington you look at this
the world is so binary and is so
oppositional you're kind of a red state
world in a blue state world and they're
so different from each other that if we
can't start passing bills and coming up
with policies that we can agree on in
some level eventually we're gonna steal
Alabama say we don't to be the same
country as California in California same
thing with same countries Alabama we're
making multiple countries yeah and the
only way to keep the Union together I
would argue is to is to start passing
stuff that's the bad news is the system
really prohibits that the good news is
and most issues that middle 70% more or
less agree right yeah take God's the 70%
would say we shouldn't confiscate
people's weapons the Second Amendment is
a real thing but people don't need
assault weapons right comment they tend
to be fairly common sense solutions on
any given issue you know immigration no
one wants to really deploy them a crazy
15% of their it--not wants at the port
of the current immigrants here but most
people do think there should be some
level of border security things like
that well it and it goes to this idea of
like take immigration right my
girlfriend which you know comes from
Eastern Europe and we talk all the time
it's like look the law is the law but at
the same time like we should change laws
yeah like what why is it so difficult to
immigrate here right it shouldn't be as
especially intact where it's like I were
literally throwing talent out there
money out the window that's just
craziness insane yeah I'm a Romney
that's when he was smart he was it was
smart when he was running for office
Murray said like I would staple a visa
to like every Farr and acceptance to
like Stanford or whatever but for
students like Harbor understand for
whatever is like here you go yeah we
want you here yeah which was the logical
policy for economic standpoint so I'm
trying to go the movement around this
thing so part of it are things like this
where you give me a chance to talk about
it publicly well I'll do it one step
further so you we've never talked about
before you don't know this but when I
was at Facebook I worked on voter
registration and so there was a team
that now known as known as social good
and goodwill I think is what they still
call it and the general mandate of the
team was hey go use all of the resources
of Facebook and all of kind of the user
base and distribution and data and all
stuff build products that are pretty
undeniably good for the world right and
don't worry about making money
so donations or you know causes like all
this kind of stuff
and one of the products that we built
was a voter registration that it was a
card that went in the newsfeed and so it
didn't tell you to vote one way or the
other didn't educate you on candidates
didn't doing this alt said was you
should be registered to vote right and I
forget the exact data so don't hold me
to it but it was like some material
percent when we first launched it we
launched it in I think was the UK it was
like 30 or 40 percent of registered
voters for that election came from that
thing in like a week yeah well that's
the beauty of having everyone staring at
the same screen is ready but hey you
should just click this button and you're
registered now imagine a weird sudden
you can actually vote people who do it
right and Facebook would never be
allowed to do that especially on
Facebook but you know but and then and
why would the politicians will basically
follow suit because they'll adapt
whatever they have to adapt to to stay
in office right so if they need to be
able to be get stuff done they'll get
stuff done right now the good news about
how little they have no way of
principles is that you could at least
you know adopt Detroit us that
represents progress so you know we're
trying to just create a movement and
watching show billions but we work with
them last year to do a mobile voting
subplot we're organizing college
campuses I'm run around the country
giving speeches and you know just trying
to basics in there we did with Rubin
Kerr let the genie out of the bottle
because I can show people hey there's a
better way to do this thing and they're
like and not shockingly in all the
polling done of people who have now
voted the soldiers who have voted online
or blocked and they're like yeah this
isn't much it had the one at dinner to
100 percent approval rating perfect I
don't would sound like we wouldn't bad
if it wasn't a hundred percent right
what was and you'll notice I don't
remember the exact details but what was
it when Al Gore and like the Chad but
the rapers it's it's funny because the
people who opposed me one of the things
they say is that any type of digital is
dangerous and they don't really
understand what blockchain is per se but
no they're not boughten it's way too
dangerous
Russia Russia did most information on
Facebook so what right even know
conceptional how these two things are
totally different so their answer is
always
paper but literally the 2000 election
was determined it by Florida it was
determined by people in West Palm Beach
who either didn't punch
the thing all the way through or they
won't punch it partially I'm and as a
result they couldn't tell who they voted
for
that's why angled in fact you had all in
or they did in a heavily Jewish
community at all the senior citizens who
according to the hanging Chad
voted for Pat Buchanan they clearly did
not vote men need to vote for Pat
Buchanan they were trying to vote for
Gore right it's like course we know that
and had that not happened Gore's
president I don't know if the Iraq war
happens I mean history is probably
pretty different right now climate
change would be hopefully much less of
an issue because that was his thing so
paper has had pretty [ __ ] significant
problems too you think Al Gore invented
the internet he thinks he does it's
funny so I've spent a little time
looking into this because such a people
will give him credit for he led the way
in Congress for appropriations to help
facilitate it okay so in terms of DoD
getting money to work on the project yes
he had some credit they didn't write a
single lot of code or yeah yeah like
that he gets some credit for at least
believing in it early to his but somehow
how that translates benefit to the
internet I don't know so the first time
I ever heard like kind of a meme right I
was like wait what and I remember going
around and I was like oh thank you
actually believe this oh yeah okay
because you're here and you're so you've
got this interesting perspective because
you understand text you understand
politics and you understand regulations
just Trump the president's geopolitics
globally like I just think about all
this so we're in a crazy [ __ ] world
right yeah
and that's true across the world not not
just us but oh yeah I mean it's it's
very my wife and the day we're trying to
like to say okay what country seem to be
like have their shift together and doing
it right oh that's an interesting
question very so who would you come up
with very few so maybe Merkel in Germany
but she says she has to leave they
pushed her out you would have said
Trudeau in Canada but he's now about to
get some out of office he had a terrible
scandal he'll turn it he was constantly
putting on blackface and I don't
understand why you'd do that but he yeah
the thing I saw was he said he was a lad
in at one point I turned I said like ten
times
so it's really hard the UK is a disaster
I guess France it's not terrible right
now you have lots of you know oligarchs
or despot in places like the Philippines
or turkey or Putin China I was gonna say
Russia and China what's the kind of
thoughts there yeah I mean obviously not
everything's going well right I mean you
have these two countries that obviously
looking out for themselves and don't
engage in democratic process which means
on one hand it's easier to make
decisions so you run better than we do
on the other hand there's no human
rights right and you know so that's that
this whole Hong Kong situation right now
it's really not sure of that so you know
the world is screwed up all over the
place but in some ways you have to
wonder is that partly because if the
u.s. is like you want to say when the
the head catches a cold the body gets
the flu or whatever the but like because
the u.s. is so wacky right now is that
then ripple effect that everything has
gone off the rails across the board
maybe right so it would seem to me that
the number one thing you would want in
the presidency would just be someone who
can not be Trump right and I you know
personally I wish Mike Bloomberg a drug
like personally to me he would have been
the best person he president but the
reality is you think of vermin
yeah he's 77 I think the last
opportunity was this and he didn't do it
I think anyone right so if you told me
it would be Warren she's not really my
kind of candidate but I'd say okay if
it's Mitt Romney nope great
you know like so Bernie Bernie I mean
not my guy but yeah I'll take him
whatever company really for sure he's
your yang I like it so are we gonna talk
here's my thing so I saw him in Philly
before he really kind of kicked off the
whole thing
right and remember kind of like yeah
that guy's I don't know but I couldn't
figure him out right and then when I saw
him running my whole take on him is he's
probably got the right platform he's
probably too early yeah so but if at
least somebody's gonna win with that
platform it's just you want this what
you think about it so like in 16
Bernie's arguing Medicare for all and in
20 it's a mainstream concept you have to
sort of take these ideas and put them
out there to the bloodstream and it
takes time to become normal but but
we are I kind of keep coming closer and
closer to yang is so Warren has this 2%
wealth tax right and on one hand in
towns totally you know Conference of
confiscatory or however you say that
word on the other hand you know when
Jeff Bezos is worth a hundred eighty
billion dollars okay maybe she's got a
point
but he's only got 90 of it now right
because Mackenzie's going the other
night right
so either way but then when you
understand governments okay we can put
all this money into the tax into taxes
but most of its gonna be wasted because
government's not good at running most of
these programs yeah so Yang's idea is
maybe not bad which is let's take some
money away from those who have it let's
give it to those who need it but let's
not let's just ride around government
through you bi right you know some basic
income that may not be a bad idea now
that the mechanics of it are tricky and
having spent so much time in corrupt
places like Illinois like the ability to
shield it from politicians sticking
their in their hands in the pot I'm not
sure about so like it's more complicated
that for sure yeah there's two pieces
right there's one like you know there's
a guy Alex Gladstein who's the chief
strategy officer at the Human Rights
Foundation and one things he's super
excited about with Bitcoin and crypto is
foreign aid so when we go give foreign
aid to most these countries it goes into
a bank account and everyone's got their
you know hand in the cookie jar and
forty percent of it ends up going to the
people who was intended for and the
other 60 percent ends up in you know the
president the dictators brother everyone
in their family and then there's you
know money that's put into the Rolls
Royce that drives everyone around right
as crazy [ __ ] and so with this you could
you know this essentially airdrop or
deposit right into digital wallets you
know exactly who got it you can track on
the talk channels kind of stuff the
other piece of it and where I come out
on like the ubi stuff which I still
don't know exactly how this works but
just from a concept standpoint we create
a lot of [ __ ] value that we don't
monetize all of our data all of this
stuff and when you get into BOC chains
and digital wallets and all the stuff is
there a way for you know rather than the
government hand you a thousand dollars a
month could you actually just sell your
digital data to corporations researchers
all the stuff and you actually might
make more money right and then what you
do is it's another way of kind of
routing
the government being involved right no
that's interesting I'm so I don't know
what is uh what's your take on on
Bitcoin specifically kind of how do you
view that in you know in concert with a
lot of the political stuff that's going
on and the mobile voting and just kind
of look it's so on one hand my fun has
investments in exchanges where Bitcoin
is clearly the most important currency
and so I want Bitcoin to do well because
I don't know means you know the value of
the exchanges tend to go in parallel
with the core sure
so I care a lot about that on the other
hand Bitcoin is a little problematic for
me because people almost nobody let's
not like a listener to your podcast like
understanding they locked you in a
Bitcoin yeah right and so when something
weird happens with Bitcoin then like my
voting thing gets attacked like see you
can't do this like it's kind of nothing
to do with Bitcoin right like weren't
even you know so like what I'm the other
ledger like you know so but that's it's
it's sometimes when narrative
perspective makes my life a little more
complicated would that sad you know
you're seeing everything the state of
Ohio is taking tax receipts now a
Bitcoin there was a candidate Brian for
Graham for Congress last time who took
his donations via Bitcoin so you know
you're seeing place children and their
life and that's the more and more
applications that real people can relate
to the more they'll start to understand
it the more they can distinguish it from
a theory and more blockchain or anything
else and the more mainstream had become
so yeah I'm for every you know I think I
do spend at least amount of time talking
to politicians I'm kind of urging them
to say look why don't you see how you
can incorporate crypto whatever you know
the corner that'll carry right into what
you do because it has potentially some
great ways to ensure provenance and
security and make sure the money goes
where it's supposed to go and it also
takes a group of people who tend to be a
little animated from government and
maybe gives them a little bit of faith a
little bit of trust we could use that
right now for sure before I wrap up I
got two questions and then you get to
end asking me a question okay a favorite
book and you can't name one that you
wrote
so not my book [ __ ] I saw I read a lot
right I really mainly fiction so I'm
going to give you oh you read more
fiction than none actually about 2/3
fiction 1/3 nah I'm like a hundred
percent non theory that apparently I'm
the gender divide is usually the way you
are guys men tend to read more
nonfiction and women more fiction by a
life issue so the best book I read this
year is a novel called boys swallows
world by then in Trent Dalton it's as
crazy book about this kid in Australia
but it's just kind of wonderful yeah and
in a fiction book fiction yeah and then
I would say sometimes I get asked his
question is when I was in like the fifth
grade I read this book called advise and
consent about like a US Senate
confirmation fight in like the 1950s and
that was what got me interested in
politics and so that book had a really
big impact on my life
I haven't read it since but people say
it's crying I'm Alan Drury but you know
that's that's how I learn what politics
was and sort of sent me on this path the
best books are all about not only the
book but also when you read them
yeah right exact I didn't really I've
told before you asked me the question
aliens believe or non-believer yeah okay
because the notion that we are the
entirety of the universe is insane to me
hell they may not be anything like what
we see in the movie he's right I have no
idea what form they take it could be
moss but we know for a fact that there
is some bacteria on Mars right some
water so like in a sense that's already
an alien right so yes could there be
beaten thought smarter than sure could
there be beings that could we turn out
to be the most sophisticated being in
universe maybe I hope not but maybe but
either way it seems so insanely
narcissistic to say that it's just us
right like we know now that there are
always galaxies and all universes all
these planets and we can only in the
same way we can only access what 3 to 5%
of our brain we're only accessing a tiny
tiny piece of the entire system right
where do you want to use for it and like
so clearly a lot of shits got to be out
there and look whether we ever interact
with it in our lifetime I don't know but
but yeah you know it may not be what the
area 51 kind of concept but I know we do
I think yes I almost don't understand
how the answer could be no what do you
think well I've asked
people in the house oh I've got a lot of
different answers and the three most
common and all ones that I agree with so
one is yours which is basically like
it's super selfish to think that we
aren't or that we are the only ones to
is mathematically just the probability
is off the charts and then the third
which is more of my favorite nut and I
don't really have an opinion about which
is uh
we may not want to discover if there's
aliens right like if somebody invades
earth like it's not usually turned out
very well for many people who have been
somewhere that's been invaded um and so
you know I think we always think about
like all would be so cool to like know
if there's other life out there but no
one ever thinks about the downside of
like actually might not want to know
right if we aren't the most
sophisticated and intelligent beings
assuming they're belligerent maybe that
species has evolved beyond that right
and so as a result maybe that they
wouldn't I who the [ __ ] knows but like
you know the same we gotta have an open
mind to most things in life I think it's
me you have to have a pen so I get to
ask you a question now yeah good so okay
this is sort of based on what I do but
like alright you've done 200 of these
yep you're an expert in crypto your
nurse burden blockchain I don't know
about all that but good I'm gonna you
are what should government be doing to
facilitate that about rules
that's a great question three things one
I think the u.s. specifically and I've
talked I was probably before I think
they should digitize the dollar
immediately and mainly because it's not
gonna be a competition between digital
versus non digital currencies is gonna
be digital first digital and so the
competition is at the monetary policy
level and the first one or two nation
backed superpower currencies that get
digitized will be more accessible than
the rest and therefore accessibility
leads to adoption right if it becomes a
standard yeah and if everyone in you
know Africa and South America
etc adopts the digital one because the
dollar isn't digital right in the sense
of tokenized huge problem for the US
dollar right so I think that's a that's
one piece that wasn't talked about
twelve months ago I think now couple of
congressmen were kind of catching on to
this so that's good too is I actually
think very similarly the US central bank
should go and put a bunch of
not in his reserves and I look at it as
less about they think that it's gonna go
to a hundred thousand million dollars
whatever it's more of it will be more
costly for them to have not done it than
to do it and it all go to 0 right so
kind of look it from a cut prisoner's
dilemma like you actually are
incentivized to do it and whether it
works out or not does it matter but like
that's the hedge yeah I think welcome
and know that even people that manage my
money like there's a certain amount
that's an alternative assets hard assets
and one of those things is Bitcoin right
and that's what that's non-correlated
yet and that's just illogical math yeah
so something that's a big one and then
the third is actually similar to what
you're doing with the mobile voting etc
is just blockchain is just triple entry
County right and it's done in an
automated fashion it keeps track of [ __ ]
right and how it flows whether its votes
its money its commodities whatever and
so I think that the government should
I'm not a fan of like the government
putting money into it per se as much as
like clearly establishing this is one of
our national focuses we are going to
heavily incentivize companies you know
individuals etc to start working on this
stuff and do it from the bent of
blockchains can unlock automation and if
we are one of the first if not the first
country to really understand how
automation can help it can't goes back
to duper stuff right what is the
production increase in the GDP if all of
a sudden people aren't spending two
three four hours a day driving a car but
instead can be doing other things yeah I
don't know I'm not a mathematician
pretty messy yeah I like I'm not a
freaking economist but somebody can
figure out that like there's gonna be an
increase in productivity right and so
you can kind of go down the line and say
like what are all the things that
automation can actually unlock right and
I'm more in the camp of automation
doesn't necessarily displace workers and
like the fear mongering way throughout
history you know was that 70% of people
used to be farmers guess what we're way
more productive because now we've got
all these machines that can do the
farming and we're able to go do more
higher impact things I think the same
thing will happen here it's just we've
really gotta figure out how to unlock a
lot of that yeah um and so when that
happens I think it'll you know we better
off for it over time that's a good
answer
I just talked about it too much all
right listen book where can they get it
Amazon probably easiest called a fixer
fixer
I'm also I have a podcast which I'm
hoping let's go
it's called firewall firewall it's
specifically about the intersection of
tech and politics your girlfriend has
been on it maybe maybe you'll join us if
you will at some point first um and you
can just get that on Spotify iTunes
wherever okay and then mobile voting you
said it is mobile voting that org is the
site that really has all the information
on it so if you want to understand the
arguments for it what's happening around
it what people are saying about it
articles it's all right there and then
if you're interested in actually being
involved you know you can put your
information in and what we'll be in
touch how do people get in touch with
you at Bradley tusk on Twitter it's
probably best way to doing it awesome I
think so much for doing this all thanks
Rodney
hey everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way in
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain